I can't remember the year I met machina
son but it was it's edging up towards
two decades now and it it was through
the introduction introduction from
aarons row and when I went to his house
we started talking we immediately hit it
off and not surprisingly one reason is
we had very similar intellectual
preoccupations particularly documentary
and theories around documentary but at
the same time there was more to our
relationship as well and I want to tell
you a story since I think it's less
perative of both another kind of
connection we shared and some may be
something about our relationship too so
once we went to kill go together to a
conference that was connected to the
festival and we even roomed together in
the hotel save some money
and he snores so I didn't sleep much one
of the things we did in addition to this
conference was take a little tour of
guilt Oh a couple libraries and shops
that he had yet to vit visit and Aaron
you might have even been on this junket
right we went on to some maybe
prefectural library and the edge of town
but he heard a whole bunch of chi joshi
from pre-war movie theaters and so we
had to go check that out so it was
wonderful just to tag along and hear him
talk to the librarians and muscle is way
in to figure out what they had and all
that but along the way on both to and
from and every day that we were there he
would see used bookstores and
everything's stopped ground to a halt
you know we had to stop whatever we're
doing go to that store and if we didn't
go in and go back later and over the
course of the trip he kept buying more
and more books and it was it was insane
you know and actually none of them had
anything to do with film they were home
they were all to supplement areas of
film you know it was like this base for
in philosophy and history literature to
support the main collection and you know
the main act anyways by the end of that
trip I was his porter
we had a suitcase worth of books and now
they're here um in any case I also share
his love of book and a paper and I both
of us we love the field we love that
smell and love the hunt too and also the
possession now taking it home writing
your name and finding the right spot on
a shelf and sliding and so this was the
basis of our relationship I think and so
today I really should be presenting some
new research to you but actually the
stuff I'm really excited about right now
is very visual and Makino is all about
text and so I've decided to go back to
an essay that is in cinema Babel and has
been anthologized a couple times for
documentary books and for a translation
reader but maybe a lot of you haven't
actually read so I'm hoping you haven't
and if you have just bear with me but I
want to do it partly because first of
all would not have been possible without
Makino ends question and second of all
as you'll learn if a piece of this
project is in the collection as well so
this is what I want to talk about and
the other thing reason I wanted to do
I mean we have a sitting on top of the
collection so we might as well do some
show-and-tell this is Paul Rafa's
documentary film it is a 1935 book from
England and it became one of the most
powerful pieces of film criticism in
theory that made its way to late
thirties Japan I mean you've opened any
book on Japanese documentary wrathe's
theory is singled out as one of the most
influential bottles plop in Japanese
film now all as if we've learned yes
last night and today many or most of the
big Western theorists from most of our
diverse kind got translated very swiftly
it could be however that none of them
were as fiercely contested and debated
as Rosa it arrived in the late 1930s and
this was a very opportune moment because
course Japan was escalating the invasion
of Japan home front on the homefront the
government message ensure that the war
was reaching into the daily lives of
people there drawing on young men for
cannon fodder increasingly controlling
appropriate behavior there were police
pressure including mass arrests
imprisonment and education torture on
the noisy left which essentially fell
apart and people either did an
about-face or went underground by
mid-decade and at the very same time the
government was putting all these
strictures on filmmaking culminating
with a 1939 film wat which mandated the
screening of documentary films which
were called boom gotta at the time of
culture films so along with just the
pressures of having
war there a continent the that
legislation propelled wrote this book
into the public discourse and
documentary itself achieved a level of
prestige comparable to the fiction film
and maybe a level of prestige that it's
never enjoyed anywhere in the world at
any time so in this atmosphere wrote
this book and especially the 1938
translation which is right here
electrify the film world now I just want
you to look at this thing and I brought
this head home so this is boom guy yovan
this is the rough a book and what's
striking to me about this is look at
that slip case it's just beautiful
this this is a project that was put
together in love you know and the whole
book is it's a beautiful book and once
it came out it was afforded this
incredible authoritative respect and
this interest in the discussions about
eventually filtered into filmmaking
practice itself allowing bro thought to
leave a mark on the history of Japanese
cinema that you know it's pretty unusual
to see this the extent to which a
theorist puts his mark on practice now
why Rosa you might ask because actually
people in documentary studies in the
West actually don't pay that much
attention to him anymore very few people
talk about him they talk about John
Grierson instead but I think one reason
is simply that wrote this book appealed
equally to the entire political specific
spectrum at the time with all the
debates participants claiming in two
different kinds of ends and so what I
want to do is examine precisely the
struggle over me at various levels and
root out the most important issues by
looking at an arena that's maybe less
obvious to us and that is the media
through which growth of thought came to
be known in the first place and that's
translation so I consider one very
simple example from the book this 1938
edition miss translates the term workers
revolution as roll dolo scottsville or
worker at workers activities now later
when it was republished in
for and this is another measure of
respect growth of God this is a 1960
version this is a 1976 version there's
even another one after this in this
version you can read that same section
and find grow delicious cup cumin or a
revolution so I mean the reason is
obvious right that that revolution was a
dangerous term to use in 1939 it would
if you even if you try to put it in the
book it would just never pass censorship
so they just swallowed it but while
there are many examples of this and
throughout the book and analysis of that
kind of simple and probably this
intentional mistranslation only gets us
so far and that's because first as the
example above there were entire as this
example suggests there were entire
communities of readers out there that
were forced to really kind of conceal
their real relationship to the spot and
second because as if soon became known
the command of english by this
translator was less than perfect she was
actually didn't know English that well
and it became one of the issues in the
debates around the book I think we've
got to dig much further into this issue
of translation to appreciate the
complexity of discourses circling round
worthless text once it arrives in Japan
first of all very few filmmakers and
critics could read English in the first
place they couldn't take the original in
hand also by shifting our analysis from
it helps us shift our analysis from
simplistic notions of one-way influence
to larger kinds of issues such as the
way that you can look at the sheer
volume of translation
know a lot about the relationship
between cultures or the lack of
translation and what that says about the
relationship or short circuits of desire
and when bringing text from one language
to another the translators approach to
language and meaning is inseparable from
larger historical and ideological
currents in the target language and this
new linguistic and cultural context
often bears pressure down on the
original and the translation well have a
little to do with the original text set
so in this situation where we end up we
actually end up with competing
translations circulating amongst
overlapping readerships and a struggle
over authority over the text because
after all can there be a more powerful
position than over cross cultural
discourse then add the translator so I
want to look at the qualities of a given
translation asked through the translator
was what's the translators relationship
to the original the author and the
larger community of readers these are
all key factors in the relationship to
the other and from this perspective and
from this perspective the difference
between translation theories and
documentary film theory is actually
seems slim because both involves fields
of representations way by a debt to
original whether it's a source text or
the world so let's look at how r othas
book entered Japan
and it's filled world originally the
first person apparently who picked up on
this was a moment I hate who we were
talking about yesterday yes last night
preeminent free war film theorists and
critical he passed it on to a producer
at domaine sushi kawano together and
from there it just searched into the
documentary film community at one point
it came into the hands of oxy bean taco
onca he was one of the first female
filmmakers after the one we heard about
earlier today she was a one of the
central members of the protein Oh
leftist collective and then he went she
went on to become an essayist and
screenwriter now above and beyond our
own film bank filmmaking activities her
most influential project was the
translation that resulted in this book
she did this at the request of her
supervisor at the studio at pcl who is
moving to jail to become a head of
production he wanted to use this as a
textbook for teaching how to do
documentary in the studio and to use it
instead in study groups essentially
that's what had been reading the
original and such as she she took on the
project gave her a good excuse to finish
it she said and it came out in a fall of
1938 the translation had an enormous
impact and it went into second and third
printings within the year the books
influence quickly spread and critics
started to baby what were thought mint
and the implications
and for their filmmaking practice and
along the way they started wondering
about translation they started really
thinking about you know what words meant
and as they looked at the translation
they started debating whether it was
good or not and you started getting new
translations the most prominent being by
a guy named bueno Ichiro now I was going
to bring these in he in a series of
essays he does the first half of this
book one after one month after the other
it's in a magazine called yoga kinky
which has yet to reach the surface in
the marking equation it's in there
somewhere but when all also a little bit
later published this this was at the de
quest of total and the yoga studio and
what it is is the lips what it is is the
last part out of the book and what's
amazing is it it's just it's minion
draft
spital focus
it's a mini of graphic copy you know so
this was the textbook being used at pole
whole film studios which would became
one of the most important producers of
documentary film and the weight on so
Luanne who became also a participant in
the base in the press along with his
translations both published probably in
that journal and then even privately in
this textbook for toefl film studios and
the bait debate of course was the
relationship of fiction and documentary
at this point when documentary was
infiltrating the fiction film and when
they started writing scenarios for for
documentaries and you say the two forms
starting to come close and closer and
closer together so what happens however
is relatively innocent looking debates
about actuality and fiction allottee
were veiling struggles over
documentaries function in Japanese
society now the written record on this
on these discussions is decidedly
one-sided Rafa was proposing a
nationally sponsored documentary film
committed to the enlightenment and
unification of the citizenry cisely the
kind of cinema necessary for a country
involved in foreign warfare and trying
to keep the nation state together right
but under the restrictive circumstances
of 1930s Japan many other important
perspectives when unreported and
undebatable and they're surely happening
offstage this aspect of rose
feel especially his sympathies for
socialism necessarily him to be
concealed from the public sphere and
they were restricted to private
discussion it doesn't you don't really
find it in the written record and of
course this closest all sorts of
challenges to this historian like me but
there are traces remaining and I think
they give us little entry points for for
thinking about other ways people were
reading growth up and that's what I want
to give you attitude right now now like
first of all like many other of the
leftists that went underground and ended
up in the documentary film world atsumi
was clearly found row 'this writing
inspirational here was a filmmaker who
is committed to so social change some of
them saw the cinema as a medium for
critiquing everything from class
discrimination to totalitarian political
systems and having spent the last decade
of her life immersed in Marxism and
dedicated to using small gauge cinema to
move the masses and bring it to and
bring the revolution she found a true
compatriot in alrosa documentary film
became this quote unquote hidden sacred
book of these filmmakers this is a term
that they use after the war to describe
what it was like for them during the
work and you can actually I found one
place where he can really sense in on
Sony's intense relationship with Rosa
and that was in her own copy of this
book which is deposited in
and when I opened it up I found that
there were three marginalia in the book
and that's it otherwise there's a clean
beautiful new cocky and those three
marginalia work dates put down in summer
of nineteen thirty nine shortly after
coming from leo's fighting soldiers have
been suppressed when you know a lot of
weight was being felt by the filmmakers
in the documentary world and these three
quotes are fascinating and I'm not going
to read them all to you but I'll read
one of them and you can sense the sort
of pleasure in double reading or finding
an avenue to read Rosa against the grain
as a word this is a the Rafah quote that
she quote that she wrote a date down in
June twenty eighth nineteen thirty-nine
relative freedom of expression for the
views of the documentalist will
obviously vary with the production
forces he serves and a political system
in power in countries still maintaining
a parliamentary system discussion and
projection of his beliefs within certain
limits will be permitted only so long as
they do not seriously oppose powerful
vested interests which most often happen
to be the forces controlling production
under an authoritarian system freedom is
permissible provided his opinions are in
accord with those of the state for
social and political events until
presumably such a time shall arrive when
the foundations of the state are strong
enough to withstand criticism ultimately
of course you will appreciate that you
can either make films on themes of your
own choice noreply treatments to us
ceptin themes unless they are in
sympathy with aims of the dominant
system and in view of the mechanical and
hence expensive materials of zoom it
will be foolish of the documentalist if
his sympathies do not lie or at least
appear to lie with those who can make
production a possibility I mean you can
just tell that for a leftist filmmaker
making propaganda films for the war
effort that this was a very attract
imeem this was her life right there
encapsulated in a quote and the other
two places are very much like that as
well so this is one of these places that
allow sort of access to more hidden
spaces unwritten resisting discourses
but this is only half the story to to
render these kinds of discourses visible
I think we want to return to the problem
of translation because on the one hand I
see you leave to a point of view it is
the very fabric of a translation both in
conscious and in unconscious ways at the
very same time intellectuals from far
different perspectives were engaging her
and kind of battle the translators now
in the course of researching my
dissertation which was when I
encountered this stuff and I was writing
on the first 50 years of translation I
was collecting books and everywhere I'm
and you know I would go through all of
the news bookstores constantly going
back and forth and if I would even pick
up books that I already had and one of
them was this one and i remember in a
bookstore between waseda and talking
Wolof I found this one hold it down and
pick it out of this book case and I've
opened it up and my jaw drop because
what I found was this this is what i
would call the case a bottom because
this is what it looks like what it
looked like see if i can get focused
every page every single page is
corrected the entire book front to that
and in the near the frontispiece there's
this text which says this is a
surprising book she can't understand
English Japanese is pretty bad even mrs.
ms at sudeep cannot argue with this I
don't understand how this person had the
guts to translate this caused the chaos
in this country's food guide at this
course oh I'm sorry these Corrections
are a year late so I took him a year to
do this and then there's this very
interesting sprawl here now I brought
this back to machina yeah the next week
I show and I pulled it out show him my
discovery he looked at it was like after
a few minutes of looking at this his his
eyes were gleaming man hey man he would
be closed it and said I have this
of course as his quarter he could say
nothing but of course you can as long as
you give me your copy and the one with a
really nice slip case so we traded and I
hit you know we tried to make sense of
this thing now I noticed that I brought
in Xerox copy that's because we can't
find we can't find it in the collection
so I'm assuming that monkey Hassan is
watching this on video and we were
wondering if you maybe hopefully will
appear in a box some you in any case we
could not figure out who did this
because they were really none names
until I was blowing through one of the
many folders and that stacks of things
that we gave me and this was shinju a
bunch of programs from the Shinjuku Ava
an angel and their programs are called
Bugatti the news
you can see nice programs a lot of these
Japanese programs are wonderfully neat
you know they've got text and articles
and then one time I finally came across
this one which is of course the cover to
the book and a piece on roses roses
documentary film and the beginning of
this blew me away because the very
beginning of this essay says below let
us pick out two or three parts of
interest from a corrected text pretty
much black with Corrections this is the
guy who ordered the taste a bummer and
then when I decided by sonnets and I
immediately pulled out the pace a bond
and of course what this entire thing is
is a set of quotations from the pace a
ball one after the other and the author
is Seconal yoshioka who was involved in
mobile shell the Department of Education
and a lot of things for for instance
chill children film days and things like
this and second of wrote a whole series
of essays in other places like this
journal all this is is strains of new
translations from the from the pace a
bomb but i am not going to bore you with
these very close announced as i do with
this but essentially what i do and if
you really want to see it you can go to
cinema babel the whole chapter and there
on the translation of film theory what I
found in analyzing the taste a bomb
Santino's translations Otsu these
translations and Buenos translations was
a battle over meaning and authority over
Rosa and by extension over documentary
film itself and sakina was a bureaucrat
and he was essentially pulling it into
the national project and his rotations
are very selective and his
transcriptions of the case a bond are
themselves translations and
interpretations and sort of taking the
taste a bondages of all of the
translations the best and directing it
towards the national project on soubise
is filled with mistakes which because
the mistakes are still in the post for
versions where she had help from even
like film theorists us anymore obviously
she just didn't understand English well
enough but it's filled with her
imaginative interpretations of what
wrote that must have been saying as well
and you can see where her sympathies
lies and we know is kind of somewhere in
the in the middle very wishy-washy kinds
of turn China choices whenever anything
political comes up so this is
essentially what i wanted to present to
you this kind of research that the
monkeyville collection makes possible
and it allows us to go and see for
instance the second a film's where if we
heard about earlier today were a mix of
fictive and documentary kinds of styles
and understand exactly what this is the
world that she was embedded in those
films look that way because of these
kinds of debates in the ways that these
translators were taking this foreign
thought and massaging it debating it
diverting it subverting it and
everything else I'll stop there thank
you